okay it's official joining the mcu
finally
how does it feel because i feel like
it's a lot of secrets to be keeping in
yeah yeah
man it's so you know it's really
emotional i'm finding it really
emotional i thought i you know emotion
emotionally i had put this to bed you
know this character was done for me and
we'd moved on and
and um
you know and suddenly i get this phone
call and
you know a few a couple of years later
and we're gearing up to do our show all
over again
um it's
it's it's feels too good to be true i'm
so excited
yeah so you grieved this character and
now i came back
yeah that's exactly it i was like you
know there was this this amazing save
daredevil campaign yeah and they're so
gung-ho and trying to get word out and
trying to get signatures and stuff and
i'm at home thinking guys it's over let
it go it's done
you know
and uh
and
you know look what they achieved yeah
here we are they did something amazing
what does it feel like to be a fan
favorite
i don't know that's
embarrassing i don't know i love this
character i love i love my job
um i've i've been surround this from the
beginning the first time we started this
i've been surrounded by the most
incredible creative people yeah
including the show runners and all the
directors and vincent d'onofrio and the
other cast amazing cast from the show
that we did before
and
you know we've
we've made something special and now we
hope to make something even more special
yeah well you're definitely the favorite
it's okay you can blush about it um is
there anything you can share i know
there's a lot of secrets still but there
is not everything that they've said is
all i know okay um and i actually had
dinner for the first time with some of
the some of the gang last night
um some of the
the writers and stuff and i was like
what can you tell me and they're like
nothing
i'm like nothing's changed then
thank you congratulations
thank you